Narrator: Both the video and audio collections of June Jordan reflect three decades of her appearances
on public radio and BBC radio, as well as television,
often in interview or appearing
as a guest expert in her field.
In addition, there are also a great deal of live poetry readings, musical performances, public lectures,
and politically charged rallies and
panel discussions videotaped for posterity.
During this panel discussion
on the show, Essence, circa 1985,
Jordan addresses the recent release
of the film, The Color Purple,
and the dearth of African American filmmakers
or story lines generally.
June Jordan: Where The Color Purple is
concerned, whether you like it or don't like it,
this is what I would like to say,
emphatically as I possibly can:
it's not about Alice Walker;
it's not about any single
black writer out here, or poet.
The problem is, that the coun--
this country is set up
in such a way that black people--
we do not have access to mass media.
Consequently, we do not have
ten and eleven black films a year,
which is what we should have.
We should not have one every ten years,
we should have ten or eleven every year.
And then the burden of our dreams and
our fears--both--
would not fall unduly on any one of us.
Any one of us is just that: one.
Jordan's audiovisual collections enrich
study of her papers.
We can listen to Jordan reading her own poems
as they are meant to be heard and,
as in the case of talks delivered at universities
or in leading her Poetry for the People class,
witness her vibrant and encouraging
performance style of a different kind--
as a professor and mentor.
And if I, if I ever let love go
because the hatred and the whisperings
become a phantom dictate I obey
in lieu of impulse and realities
the blossoming flamingos of
my wild mimosa trees,
then let love freeze me out.
I must become--I must become--
a menace to my enemies.